grand carmichael congrats i'm getting
lego minutes done thank you god
came out really well
slow clap
we're getting slower we're supposed to
get faster turned out awesome congrats
you guys are working so hard on it it
was a fun video to do something else
that's really cool is the store
had 51 hats ordered over the past couple
hours yeah i pointed to my computer as
if my computer had something on the
screen limited edition run so that means
any hats ordered within a certain amount
of time are good we have 10 days from
today
to get as many hat orbs as we can and
then we will stop selling them and we
will
make as many hats as we have orders uh
other good news
uh last night i asked ivy to marry me
[Music]
well awesome i'm happy for you
congratulations empty shopping cart
you guys are on the blue team so you're
the sniper right let's just run the red
team now pushing the car down the street
any kind of quiet street will do
is there a nerf sniper rifle
this is the one gun i'm kind of excited
about
it's like a 50 cal mag
i think the other key issue is if we're
going to be the cart people then you
need to bring on the dp we'll get there
okay because that's a big that's a huge
aspect
especially shooting for all the vfx
what's the deal with the silly string
medic is going to have a little bio
squad gun which shoots silly strings the
idea is in the game when you're killing
somebody as the medic it makes a gun
that shoots like a healing beam it's
kind of like a ghostbusters gun
if you ever wonder why ren's in most of
the videos it's not just because he's a
very charismatic individual which is
very true it's cause i'm right next to
the cameraman carmichael just leaves the
camera on and pointed at rain all the
time
tomorrow we're shooting nerf team
fortress and gotta go and kind of figure
out where exactly we're gonna shoot it i
have a vague idea
so red and i are looking for nine
costumes for our nerf team fortress 2
video some red players and we've got to
get some blue players and we've got to
borrow
a local shopping cart
flip around to the side there
we've got a spray paint the engineer
helmet and also we could do the knee
pads the same color
pretty sure losing
oh
no more video
no
oh
current review of the nerf sniper rifle
is it sucks
little piece of broken plastic right
here
brett and i have successfully gathered
all the costumes and all the props looks
like i'll be playing the pyro and the
medic so you know look for me in the
credits guys
[Music]
should definitely cover in the vlog